investigators are working to find out
why a World War 2 era plane crash that
Connecticut's largest airport killing at
least seven people the b-17 bomber was
trying to make an emergency landing at
Bradley International Airport after
engine problems ten passengers and three
crew members were on board Kris Van
Cleave is at the airport Kris what more
do we know about the accident
well good morning this b-17 was a bit of
a flying museum that was on a national
tour I'm gonna step out of the way I
want you to look at this runway right
back here it's runway 6 the NTSB is
going to be looking very closely at it
because that's where the plane came down
before it veered to the right eventually
hitting a building we can pan over you
can see the tail of the plane is right
next to a dump truck they're in the shot
now there were six people on board who
survived three were critically hurt two
others on the ground including a
firefighter were also injured dark black
smoke filled the Connecticut sky moments
after the 75 year old b-17 bomber
crash-landed off the runway at Bradley
Airport with 13 people on board I
thought boy I hope it makes the airport
Claire Palmer saw the plane moments
before the crash it was sputtering and
popping noise and I thought what's the
matter with that engine the four engine
propeller driven plane took off at 9:45
Wednesday morning just five minutes
later the pilots made that emergency
call and at 954 they landed short of the
runway at Bradley and crashed into a
nearby de-icing facility and maintenance
building the left wing is broken off and
there are various pieces of plane across
the facility
Jennifer Hamid II is with the NTSB are
you surprised people survived this crash
this was a significant tragedy and from
the scene I am surprised that people
survived
Robert Riedel a world war two buff is
one of the passengers who died in the
crash they paid as much as four hundred
and fifty dollars for a 30-minute ride
Wednesday Riedel posted this picture
from inside the doomed plane his family
said this flight was on his bucket list
Reidel son told us at least he was doing
something he loved now there are only
about 10 flying b-17s left they
typically don't have black boxes so the
NTSB will be looking for any electronics
cameras cell phones anything that may
have some information to help them
understand what happened onboard Gayle
Chris that last picture tough to see
thank you very much